thank you holla you don't look any worse
than where for having been on those
front lines
well it was quite the experience
and many times you were there in the
important discussions and debates that
were going on as
the world leaders were grappling to find
answers so help us understand what
happened what didn't what in your
opinion were the outcomes of cop26 thank
you pat and hello everyone
in short we made progress
but we are not on track to deliver the
world we need
and i'm a stubborn optimist so i want to
uplift the ground we took because it was
important ground
but i also want to be very clear that i
left glasgow with a very visceral
feeling that there was this gaping
generational and trust gap
that we are almost unable to bridge
because we have become so deeply divided
and and we're essentially in a crisis of
trust
and so we're facing an existential
climate crisis but the greatest barrier
may be that we don't have trust
and so let me try to give you a few
things
to feel hopeful for that i do think came
out of this cup because i think it
matters for us to spring into action to
have hope
and so what i would like to uplift
number one
is that i think the agenda the climate
agenda is becoming more holistic than it
has been it's no longer just about
reducing greenhouse gas emissions as
important as that is nature is on the
agenda and we're at least talking about
justice and inclusion we weren't doing
that just a few years ago now we need to
act on it but at least we're talking
about it so more holistic agenda second
i believe this cop will be remembered as
the cup where business and finance
showed up and we can say that doesn't
matter because the co-op process is
created for governments but that matters
so much governments cannot solve this
alone we need public private partnership
and we need to be working with civil
society we need radical collaboration
and i feel like that's starting to
happen i have some hope in that and then
third we saw some unlikely alliances we
saw
well b team leaders and other business
leaders stand with the climate
vulnerable forum countries that are
contributing the least to this problem
but are being hit the hardest by then
and we saw business leaders standing
there with presidents of countries that
are dealing with terrible situations
demanding that the global north deliver
the 100 billion for the global south and
then some
to help mitigate this crisis and and
last but not least we had actually
accountants show up as the change
catalysts that may change the world and
who would have thought
but we announced the international
sustainability standards board and this
may not mean anything to many of us but
it means everything to changing norms in
business because it means we're going to
start measuring and disclosing what
matters and so i think these things
should all give us hope but let me not
gloss over the fact that we had this
these gaping gaps between the inside and
the outside that actually left me
feeling that we have so much hard work
to do now
we can't leave that moment behind us we
right now must rise we have a narrow
window to deliver this future we need
and it is going to take all of us
leaning in not just around one global
moment but in a one global movement of
private sector public
servants and civil society actors and
activists coming together in a more
radically radically collaborative way
than we ever have before
among the most hopeful outcomes was one
you referenced is that business leaders
stepped up and that was in large part
because of the leadership of the b team
who are business leaders committed to
becoming more accountable into creating
sustainable business practices going
from being the perpetrators to the
problem solvers so how is that happening
yeah well let me start by saying the b
team leaders uh are not perfect none of
us honestly are
but
they are global leaders from business
and civil society who have decided to
put humanity at the heart of their
leadership compass and do the hard work
to meet the climate crisis the crisis of
inequality and the crisis of trust we
are facing and so we're showing up
placing the well-being of people and
planet alongside the pursuit of profit
and that is long overdue
but it is fortunately now becoming
more
of a mainstream agenda than when the b
team was founded seven years ago
and so we've been on this journey for
seven nearly eight years now and we've
just put out something we call the new
leadership playbook and ten times
boulder podcast where we are actually
sharing the
the journeys the stories of transforming
businesses
to be in service of a better world and
going deep in the conversations of why
we do that as human beings and actually
sharing the questions we should be
asking now because this is not a moment
where we have all the answers but we
know we need to be asking the hard
questions and sharing some of the
resources that can help businesses and
leaders who want to go on this journey
because the window is now and we need
everyone to join us
and more importantly while in cop we put
out a statement where we put out our
assessment of what was going on in
glasgow and we promised to convene a
global dialogue of multiple stakeholders
in 2022 it could be dialogues where you
have to design it but really bring
people together across these deep
divides because there is no way from
here
to where we want to go a future where we
can love where we live
by going it alone anymore it's going to
take radical collaboration and we can't
love where we live
unless we keep the world on track for
1.5 degree warming
above pre-industrial levels unless we
bring nature into the solutions and
start reversing or holding first and
then reversing nature laws and unless
we start making this about a just an
inclusive transition for all of humanity
and this is
this is going to be the hardest work we
ever do but we created this world so we
can co-create a world where we love
where we live and i don't know a single
human being that doesn't feel deeply
frustrated with the moment we are in
and is interested in navigating this
transition to a better future and that's
the work that we have to do in the next
eight years
most difficult work of our lifetimes has
to happen in the next few years
the b team and other business leaders
who were there you've also developed
some really specific actions some things
you need you believe need to change
share this with us yeah so if we want to
love where we live
we have to change who
to change how we lead run businesses and
our economy
what do we mean by that without closing
the gender racial ethnic generational
global north global south gaps around
every table so we can start redesigning
the table
we are not going to be able to design a
world that is trusted inclusive and
works for all
right now
it is
a rather male and a rather pale world
and you all know what the third thing is
that's going to give us a rather
stale world well
that is not
what we need now we need the greatest
human transformation of our lifetimes to
happen now and that should be exciting
it's a huge business opportunity it's a
huge opportunity to unite people
and it's a huge opportunity to create a
world that works for all
but we have been going about this with
sameness or conformity
in leadership i have said before we
suffer from a crisis of conformity and
leadership so the only way to disrupt
that is to bring difference to bear we
have to close these gaps in leadership
no later than by 2025 it should be on
everybody's agenda to close these gaps
in every leadership room in every design
room everywhere but we also have to
rethink what leadership is it is no
longer something that comes only from
people in positions of power leadership
is and has always been something that is
inside out
it's in all of us and the greatest work
we do in life is to unlock it in service
of something that we care about
and so changing who to change how is
also about changing you to change how
and about each of us doing the work to
come from the inside out
bring our humanity to bear bring our
courage to bear
drop from our heads to our hearts more
often
because business schools our
capitalistic system has trained us
overly much on the left brain left side
of our brain only
and
we won't be able to calculate our way
from where we are to where we need to be
in excel alone
technological
transformations are critical and we have
a lot of them in place and a lot of them
underway and we clearly have enough
money in the world but those things may
not be matching up the missing piece is
transformational leadership
so we need to drop from our heads to our
hearts and unlock courage and what we
care about and our humanity and we need
to face the truth
that our economic system may have served
some well for a long time may still be
serving some
but has failed to serve the many for
quite some time so unless we reset and
write the rules in our economic system
and align the incentives with the future
we're trying to deliver we are going to
be unable to do it
and let me just give you a couple of
facts we are currently our governments
are spending 11 million dollars a minute
in subsidizing fossil fuels
and a year 1.8 trillion dollars into
subsidies that are environmentally
harmful
so we go to glasgow and we set goals for
the future and then we go home and we
invest in the past
this is insanity if i've ever seen it so
it is
so brave leadership matters and that's
what the b team leaders are trying to do
and we need a lot more people to join us
but brave leadership in a broken system
isn't going to work so we have to write
the rules we have to change who to
change how and if we
and i say i say change who to change how
is the transformational level it's going
to help your company become future fit
it's going to help unlock the innovation
you need so it's a lever to lead the
transformation but let's not excuse the
role of governments governments have to
write the rules they have to align the
incentives they have to require business
to measure what matters
such important actions that
must leave us all thinking though if we
what is the one thing that we can do our
friend mary robinson says make it
personal make the climate crisis
personal how do we do that
well for me it's incredibly personal i
carry mother earth and i'm now changing
it to daughter earth around my neck it
was a gift from my husband and two
children but as a ceo of the b team as a
mom i care deeply about this i care so
much about it that i even ran for
president at some point and so i and i'm
just a little girl from iceland who just
thinks that what i care about matters
and that i can unlock my authentic voice
and values in service of a better future
so so can all of us in here
so um bearing that maybe not all of you
will want to run for president
you have
but i hope many of you will really think
about it because it's one of the best
things i've ever done yet the hardest i
think the first thing i would advise all
of you to do is to drop from your head
to your heart and really craft your own
compass and let your leadership align
with that and then use your voice your
your
votes and your wallets according to that
moral compass because as human beings we
know we we know truth from fake news we
know the work we need to do
so
moral compass and then use your voice
it's the most powerful tool we have use
your votes and help everybody else have
the opportunity to use that and use your
vote with your feed you know so work for
companies and do business with companies
that actually are aligned with your
compass
and then use your wallets
and ask questions when you're spending
money when you're investing money when
you're choosing a bank
you have so much power but
make sure whatever
you choose to do that you don't
underestimate that the most powerful
lever around to drive the transformation
right now is collective power of
employees
and they are really making their voice
and votes matter now and power has
shifted emerging power has more power
now so wherever you are
mobilize bring people together put
pressure on politicians put pressure on
ceos it's actually few actors
that can really change this but many
actors can help them see that time is
out
and time for courageous and brave
leadership is now demanded
thank you for your leadership paula use
your vote your wallet your voice
thank you